up next a discussion on former national
security advisor and Secretary of State
Henry Kissinger Harper's Magazine
recently published two articles by
Christopher Hitchens accusing mr.
Kissinger of international crimes
participants at today's National Press
Club event included Kissinger staff
member Roger Morris three law professors
and mr. Hitchens Harper's editor Lewis
Lapham served as moderators it's about
an hour to half okay I'm my name is
Lewis Lapham this is a discussion of a
two-part essay appearing in the February
of March issue of Harper's Magazine
making the case against Henry Kissinger
record and written by Christopher
Hitchens who is an author a columnist
for the nation author of many books TV
shows and so on and we also have Scott
Armstrong another well-known author
formerly the director of the National
Security Archive Stanley Cutler
well-known professor of American history
in Wisconsin author of many books most
recently of the Nixon tapes and the
abuse of power
Roger Morris who is formerly on the
National Security Council with Nixon
again the author of many books and most
recently I think he's writing one about
Las Vegas that's correct
Alfred Rubin is the professor of
international law at the Fletcher School
Diplomacy at Tufts University is himself
an author of several books an authority
on the old British Empire is it correct
I think and the subtext of the
discussion this morning is are we an
empire or a democracy is there a way
can we behave in the manner of the old
Roman Empire and do as we please with
the world drop bombs on people we feel
to be communist or seditious in one form
or another whoa people to be well rid of
in other words can we behave in an
autocratic manner without accountability
that is the record of mr. Kissinger x'
career as national security adviser in a
Secretary of State were he a private
citizen living in a democracy he could
be brought to justice
conceivably hanged as a statesman
operating under the Dada senior of
senior statesman a servant of the
American Empire under the rubric of the
Cold War he escapes all not censure but
any kind of act of bringing him to
account the piece the two essays written
by Christopher and Harper's Magazine
present the record of mr. Kissinger and
then raised the question is it possible
to hold such a man accountable and at
the same time it is raising the question
of what kind of country do we think we
live in do we wish to live in and so
Christopher you can begin with a brief
precis and then we will work it down the
table starting with Scott and going to
Stanley get any into the questions also
of information what kind of historical
record are we making
does mr. Kissinger have the right to
simply take away from the public domain
those records that he feels are too
sensitive to be exposed to the American
public and then we will come to
professor Rubin and to Roger Morris and
I hope that we have a an audience that
is will aggressively ask questions we I
would like the various people on the
panel to talk for maybe 45 minutes and
then we will open the the conversation
to questions from the audience and then
I hope that you will address them your
questions to a specific panelist and
maybe we will have an illuminating
morning you can begin Christopher
Thank You Lois well and thank you ladies
and gentlemen for coming I'm acutely
conscious of in the first place having
already had my say so to speak at some
length and acutely conscious also of
being the only one who stands between
you and people have greater expertise
than myself but I thought I would offer
you a play on some recent words which
you may have been made to memorize these
words are a peaceful orderly democratic
transition you may have heard these
words recently uttered in a self
congratulatory not a stay self-regarding
manner you may have had the opportunity
to tire of hearing the words peaceful
orderly democratic transition you may
have wondered why you are so often
assured that the great distinction of
the United States is that that is what
it does or has or can boast of you may
even think it's slightly sinister that
you keep on being told that you have a
peaceful democratic orderly transition
tradition you may wonder even why if it
was so obvious it had to be restated so
often so I'll stop saying it myself
hoping I've made my play on words point
and direct your attention to two
elements only of my failure on on mr.
Kissinger
the first being the election of 1968 in
these United States if I can make it
claim to launch originality perhaps but
to a certain synthesis in what I've
written it would be this think I can say
that harpist is published for the first
time the the sum of all available
evidence of how that election was
undermined distorted fixed by a most
appalling piece of cynicism by Richard
Nixon than others in the course of which
they went to a foreign military
dictatorship negotiated secretly with
that dictatorship to undermine the
negotiating position of the American
government the United States government
and its legal and visible negotiators in
Paris Maeda made an illegal pact and an
amoral patch that this foreign military
dictatorship would get a better deal
from an incoming Republican
administration and in making this pact
took out what one might describe
euphemistically as a mortgage or lease
on another four years it would already
proven immoral and atrocious war and the
combination of the subversion of that
election and the extension of that war
is the price of the bargain qualified I
think to be termed without any
overstatement the single wickedest act
in the history of this Republic and it
may be doubted whether it quite
qualifies under the tradition of a
democratic peaceful and orderly
transition certainly of the of the for
people who concerted that policy Richard
Nixon General John Mitchell vice
president Spiro Agnew and Henry
Kissinger only one has escaped any kind
of indictment so far John Mitchell was
the first Attorney General to go to jail
Richard Nixon had to accept a pardon in
order to avoid indictment and
impeachment and Spiro Agnew had to cop a
plea
also there's only one unindicted
co-conspirator still on the loose I
suggest that's a reproach to a country
that considers itself to be bound by law
and bound by justice
democratic peaceful orderly transition
was also the great boast and rightly
serve of the people of Chile our
southern neighbor the country that has
never offended or threatened to offend
or had the capacity to offend or
threaten the United States it was
distinguished among its hemispheric
neighbors precisely by the fact that
when its people had voted their choice
formed the next government and the armed
forces or the police or the oligarchy
didn't determine that I couldn't
intervene in it and that will remain the
state of affairs until 1970 when it was
coldly decided at a meeting in
Washington held my mother's by dr.
Kissinger that there was to be no
peaceful democratic orderly transition
in Chile that the 60-day
constitutionally mandated waiting period
between the election of a president in
this case Salvador Allende and his
confirmation inauguration would be used
for a campaign of murder and subversion
in order that that transition not occur
and this involved the cold-blooded
planning of the murder of general Rena
Schneider the head of the Chilean armed
forces an honorable conservative and
constitutionalist officer in a country
which I repeat was a democracy that had
open diplomatic relations and trade
relations with the United States and
posed no threat to it and that murder is
now what a lawyer I think could decently
call a lay down case later on case from
soup to nuts we know who commissioned it
who paid for it who organized it who
shipped the illegal money who shipped
the jeggi weapons to Chile to have this
done and who paid the murderers after
the crime had been committed and the
same name in the same face recurs
throughout we charged Henry Kissinger
with murder for that and we say that a
society that tolerates him is tolerating
that too and that's therefore a big
reproach to society that claims to be
bound by law responsive to justice and
it's a it's of course an other cynical
negation of all the claims that have
been made about democratic peaceful
orderly transition as I said of the of
the for people who conducted the
election subversion 968 only one remains
unindicted if you now look at the
international scene and see the people
with whom dr. Kissinger was in business
during his tenure in office you will
find that almost all of them will sell
in jail in their own countries or are
going there of mr. Casillas business and
political partners mr. Suharto general
pinochet general Papadopoulos in in
greece the the brigadiers in bangladesh
who committed the assassination of
sheikh mujib
and and quite a number of others are in
jail I'm glad to say tried in courts
proper courts in their own countries and
condemned to life imprisonment
once again the grant exception is the
man who made their political careers or
military careers possible and he dwells
as a an honored citizen among us and we
say to that that is a reproach reproach
to any society that considers itself
internationally law bound or responsive
to the claims of justice on the
international scale so let that be my
opening bid and let me accept to counter
offers from war enlargements or am a
very strong bid undercuts our on my work
needs to see this gentleman thank you
Scott Christopher I'm not sure this is
directly responsive to your bid but I
think I share with you and everyone here
a deep concern about accountability in
public service it is a given to me that
with without high quality public
servants we will not have even the mere
bones of government that we now have I
encourage people that I meet young
people to go into government I encourage
them to get the experience I encourage
them to persevere I've even been known
to congratulate senior officials on
their departure from government usually
for what they don't do
a usually catalogue that I can relay to
them about their their failure to act in
a way that was suggested that would have
been worse than what they did and I find
often that they are surprised to be
thanked that they rarely are thanked
except by the corporate interest that
they are expected to represent the
difficulty of accountability it seems to
me is that if we if we don't have an
accountability for the past we will have
we will not have people willing to serve
in the future we must make some
arrangements and document them that will
allow I think the debate that we'll have
here today to be more clearly focused on
individual service it is a dangerous
violent world out there we're often told
that what public official can avoid
regional conflicts ethnic cleansing the
difficulties and harsh realities that
national security decision-making as its
as its put forward is by every
administration which generally seems to
me to mean arguments to protect American
interests that are not necessarily the
interests of the American people except
by virtue of their investment in a
corporate society and these difficulties
with dealing with a political leadership
that's that is elected to protect these
interests is most dramatically presented
in Kissinger's case there is a an adage
that I'm afraid we are we are likely to
invert the adages to make the punishment
fit the crime and I think now we
sometimes are in danger of making the
crime fit the punishment mr. Kissinger
is is in the parlance of street protests
of the 60s is already known as a war
criminal we're prepared to punish him as
such now we find ourselves ordering our
facts in order to construct the crimes
with which we're prepared for which we
are already prepared to punish him I
have some caution about this these are
not unique actions they were not covert
they are not Oliver North type
government out of control these in fact
were very
singular in their arrogance they were
openly contemptuous of many
constitutional niceties and Henry
Kissinger and those about him were very
much in control these were deliberate
manipulations of the levers the levers
of power and it was is it is very much
that Henry Kissinger was in the loop he
defined the loop and Christopher's
indictment if I can call it that is of
an entire administration stretched by
the Nixon resignation into two
administrations and those who served
with him above him across the Potomac
and even in Congress bears similar
measures of responsibility so what do we
do if we are not just to throw the term
war criminal around loosely we must dig
out analyze and order the facts the
documentary record and the forensic
explanations that are offered by mr.
Kissinger by mr. Nixon and by virtually
every other member of that
administration it is in the bureaucratic
context that we find this most
interesting and Henry Kissinger has done
something quite remarkable he's taken
most the most important of his papers
and he has hidden them in plain sight he
has installed them in the Library of
Congress under a deed which makes them
inaccessible until the year 2001 or five
years after his death and which means no
matter tragic his life may be this year
we're not going to be looking at those
for another five years
they include authentic telephone
transcripts of virtually every important
meeting he had the case that in which
this was litigated the the
appropriateness of taking government
records and putting them into the
library Congress is Kissinger against
the reporters committee the other
plaintiffs were the military audit
project and one William Safire of the
New York Times by an unusual majority
that actually only had depending on how
you read the opinions for members that
it included two concurrences and a
partial concurrence and two abstentions
we have established a rule of law that
allows one to put to put one's papers
out of the reach of the public general
Haig did this caspar weinberger did this
in fact caspar weinberger did it and was
indicted for it
he was pardoned by President Bush
because he was seen as an act of
deliberate deliberate attempt to
obstruct justice
but difficulty we now have is that there
is an ongoing investigation of General
Pinochet the FBI is very been pursuing
this more actively than it's been
publicly reported but even public
reports acknowledge that there's now
enough information to indict in the
United States General Pinochet however
the best evidence is evidence it's in
the Library of Congress the FBI is
getting that evidence and is getting
some access to it but it has to
negotiate with Henry Kissinger lawyers
these are government records that the
United States government in a criminal
investigation is negotiating access to
there are a variety of things that
Kissinger has done that that we will
find I think elucidated by these
materials but the most important aspect
is this is that his staff and he have
had complete access to this material and
with a very carefully selected and
shaped account Henry Kissinger has put
himself beyond the control of a of his
history beyond the memory of those who
might refute it it will be very unlikely
that in five years this material would
be accessible Library of Congress has
conspired some degree to to support this
what are we to do now how do we approach
this I don't think there are simple
answers well well here I'm sure in a
minute about crimes against humanity and
international prosecutions my concerns
are much more American law and the
ability to get some sort of truth and
reconciliation process Henry Kissinger's
defense which was quite deliberately
articulated just the other night at
McNeil lair was that much of this was
done in the name of the Cold War and in
Cole he said we may have been wrong but
we genuinely believed that we had to do
something about Chile and other places
to prevent communist takeovers well I
think it's time that we understood what
the range of those activities were
Christopher's laid them out quite
clearly one of the more interesting
rebuttals to the notion that there
should be international accountability
was given by John Bolton one of the
people from the Reagan administration so
with such responsibilities who testified
in this administration
that this would not be an adequate
deterrence to the activities of
dictators like Pol Pot or Saddam Hussein
that an international court of criminal
justice would not deter them and yet I
remember sit sitting and listening to
John Deutsch explained that he was very
disturbed that the records of a Central
Intelligence Agency director before him
might be released after 40 years and his
remark was imagine if those were
released if I knew that those were going
to be released it would change the way I
treated my peers and the intelligence
community from other countries it would
change my behavior precisely so the
notion of accountability seems to be
such a shock within government and it's
the one of those rare opportunities I
think to see that the obvious lies right
on the surface and so the empirical
issues of chain-of-command claims the
responsibility efforts to affect the
outcome the very things that we see in
government decision-making are now
something that we have an opportunity
and I think a responsibility to demand
and to call for whether it's done by
legislation whether it's done by a
commission I fear a commission and who
would appoint a commission but there
needs to be some mechanisms of
accountability to lay out the record and
complete it the christopher's of a gun
to describe family well
the Scot touched on some of the issues I
wanted to mention but the reiterate a
few of them first of all a problem with
the Christopher's indictment here is
that Senator Helms
has made it clear that he will block any
treaty that would turn any American over
to foreigners for war crimes trials
I suspect that Senator Helms might like
to make an exception for Henry Kissinger
but not necessarily on Christopher
Hitchens as grounds but one's reflecting
his own prejudices one's own agenda the
let me just say a few words briefly
about the work it's it's quite
devastating I think it's built on a lot
of first-rate digging into primary
sources paralleling I would tell you a
lot of the work that's going on in the
scholarly history history community
these days you know the director of the
Nixon Library is always argued just wait
till all the good stuff comes out and
Nixon's reputation will be rehabilitated
well perhaps you're not aware but there
are books let's say now on Nixon in the
economy
Nixon an agriculture Nixon and Vietnam
and so forth all of you which making
extensive use of the Nixon papers which
include things of Henry Kissinger as
well and I will tell you he ain't doing
so well it's very very clear I think
where this historical record is going it
would take massive revisionism to turn
it around and I just don't see that in
the cards it's interesting that
Christopher touched on a number of
issues there's there's work on that's
been done on Vietnam some on Chile but
no work on Cyprus among historians not a
nothing on Bangladesh and nothing of
course on the distinguished gentleman
from Greece Elias P Dimitri Coppola
saboom
Christopher wrote at length and what
happened to him here
apparently I'd like to
just say that when I interviewed John
Mitchell a number of years ago I asked
him about Demetri couple us what he knew
about that this is the man that
Christopher points out in the article
whom somebody reported was livid with
Dimitra capitalist and was going to get
him and so forth he told me he was in a
very serious mood that day that was the
day that he gave me an advance peek into
the notion that there was a prostitute
call ring at the Democratic National
Headquarters and John Dean masterminded
the whole Watergate break-in for whom he
has a an audience of one namely G gordon
Liddy the Mitchell told me then that
last bout to Metropolis he said never
heard of him
and no so after III don't have this on
videotape and it didn't show up on
audiotape
he when he explained to me his whole
notion of Dean masterminding Watergate I
said to my said you can't be serious and
he just winked at me but I can't record
that on audiotape unfortunately uh the
when we talk about Kissinger as crimes
and so forth one of the things that I
think that we have to remember here is
that Kissinger was the National Security
Advisor he subsequently became Secretary
of State now he bares a great deal of
responsibility that things were done but
I'm still a great believer that
responsibility begins really at the very
top and if we're going to talk about
Kissinger here we're going to have to
talk very very much about Richard
Nixon's culpability in all this but as
Christopher said Richard Nixon had his
comeuppance in the terms of the
resignation Spiro Agnew Mitchell but you
know the responsibility accountability
is very widespread Scott briefly alluded
to this what about leaders in Congress
I've always been bemused by this notion
of the secret bombing of Laos that
wasn't so secret a congressional
leadership knew
about that it's very interesting when
they come down to the impeachment
articles about against Nixon that there
is a proposal to impeach them on the
grounds of the secret bombing of Laos
but the leadership gets that one
withdrawn because they know their own
culpability in that matter in their own
the only the need for accountability to
them as as well so what the these are
not isolated acts they permeate as quote
policy unquote and as justified in the
name of the Cold War but it sits on a
very very broad level ah you know unless
anyone think in case anyone has
forgotten that Kissinger and believes
that kissinger's critics are all to the
left or liberals or something I would
remind you that on the right in this
country there is long been a very very
strong distrust of Henry Kissinger
there's a whole literature I mean that
this belongs in the realm of cooked um
about Kissinger being really a kernel
boor who was a secret Soviet agent and
so forth that I dismiss but I don't
think so dismissible is a man such as
Elmo Zumwalt who was the naval commander
of whom who gave us that unforgettable
remark about the Paris Peace cords he
said there are two words that
characterized the Paris Peace Accords
that that they were not there you know
it was peace with honor he said there
was uh the two things that stand out it
was neither peace nor honor involved in
those accords but he wrote in his
memoirs I had first become concerned
many months before the June 1972
burglary Watergate about the deliberate
systematic and unfortunately extremely
successful efforts of the president
Henry Kissinger and a few subordinate
members of their inner circle to conceal
sometimes by simple silence more often
by articulate deceit they're real
policies about the most critical matters
of national
purity the president Kissinger and a few
subordinate members of their inner
circle to conceal sometimes by simple
silence more often by articulate deceit
they're real policies about the most
critical matters of national security
that great leaker Alexander Haig didn't
like them either
and I've always believed that Haig had a
strong part in the Joint Chiefs of Staff
spying on on Kissinger but the let me
just turn to briefly well one one remark
about the the papers I've been aware for
some time of what Kissinger and Haig and
later Weinberger got away with by
depositing their papers in the LC you
understand that first of all the that
Congress was able to get most of the
Nixon stuff sealed off and kept from
people we have extensive files from
Alderman Ehrlichman John Dean and others
in the Nixon administration but we don't
have very much extensive on Kissinger
and extraordinarily little about
Alexander hey well you know as Scott
told you they put their papers in the
Library of Congress papers that were
generated under their duties as public
servants got the government of the
United States to pay for the cost of
processing and warehousing those
materials processing those materials I
can assure you is a very very expensive
proposition and there they sit in the
Library of Congress Henry Kissinger and
his aides have absolute access to them
Henry Kissinger and Alexander Haig have
made millions millions of dollars off
their memoirs and in pursuit of scholar
of historical truth we are forbidden to
use them now I always regretted that the
reporters committee failed to liberate
those materials
they might try my lawyer sometime and
they might have a little better success
in terms of getting getting that loose I
mean I think it's the agreement is
perfectly legal as it turns out I mean
I've gone through this with one of my
former students is on the this is pretty
high up there in the manuscript division
and he's persuaded me that there you
know there's not much you can do about
this now but if Kissinger is really
interested in defending himself well how
about putting it all out on the record
and let us see it now well I want to say
one final if in conclusion I want to say
a word about Vietnam policy I mean I
think of all these subjects this is the
one that still has the greatest allure
to us it's still an extraordinarily
seductive question there's there's been
some wonderful work done on this subject
it's an interesting book by a young man
named Jeff Kimball on Nixon's nixon in
Vietnam there's a forthcoming book this
summer by Larry Berman on Kissinger and
and M Vietnam and mr. Berman has had
access the the heart of his new material
is he's had access to the transcripts of
the negotiations between Kissinger and
Leto and you might find laid-up toes a a
frustration and anger with Kissinger to
make him a rather attractive character
how I get access without how I got just
don't know exactly but they're there
their quotes my I haven't haven't got
haven't I've read the footnotes that
extensively yeah I just got the the
manuscript but what is clear now to us
is despite the talk in 1968 I mean it's
it's very vague by Nixon about doing
something to end the war well into the
end to late 1970 Kissinger and Nixon are
convinced they could win that war they
could win that war but by late 1970
Nexen becomes concerned because of the
domestic situation in the
it states yet he's got this hang-up
about honor I don't want to be the first
president to lose the war I thought
James Madison was the first one to lose
a war something he's concerned about
that that kind of reputation he talks in
late 70 with Kissinger about withdrawing
all remaining US ground forces except
those who could be considered residual
and much by pressure on Hanoi by
canceling negotiations issuing an
ultimatum and massively bombing mining
and blockading North Vietnam now kiss
juror argued against that policy he
considered trying to bug out meaning
that a pullout by the end of 1971 would
leave them incapable of dealing with
setbacks in South Vietnam when the 1972
presidential election would take place
it would be better therefore he said to
continue with negotiations which on a
certain level were a sham and extend the
timing of troop withdrawals until the
end of 1972 and I must quote him
precisely here from one of the tape
transcripts so that we won't have to
deliver finally until after the
elections yeah peace was at hand after
the elections that's the point
now why is that indictable by his own
words it's not very good for his
historical reputation that's for sure
professor Rubin I'm tempted to respond
everybody but I'm not going to instead
I'm going to just give some legal
outlines might mention by the way I knew
buds of all 35 years ago and haven't
seen him since first of all the US
Constitution does not give authority to
the Secretary of State it gives
authority to the President to the
Congress to the courts the remedy for
evil is there for impeachment and
impeachment applies not only to
presidents but it can also applaud
congressmen and to the members of the
court non reelection another remedy in
the moral sphere
and one that's probably essential is
exposure and that's a responsibility of
the press a responsibility I'm afraid
that the press is not born terribly well
with the exception I suppose of
Christopher and some others if it's not
applied if the remedies that are
available are not applied society is
weakened we have for example a failure
to pay our UN dues is a positive law
obligation there's no question that we
owe over a billion dollars in dudes now
the press has been talking about senator
Helms being willing to approve something
over a half a million dollars as if that
were a great achievement we owe over a
billion now half a billion is not a
billion the at the same time we argue
that the UN should pursue various
activities that it cannot pursue without
money we argued in the advisory opinion
before the International Court of
Justice many years ago that France and
Russia owed money for a peacekeeping
operation in the Congo I happen to have
been in government at the time and said
we shouldn't be doing this because it
might come back against us well by golly
it has come back against us and
everybody's forgotten the argument made
in the earlier case except everybody
outside the United States the press is
certainly forgotten and I think you've
failed in your in your job because I'm
speaking of public records now there are
similar things that go on today the NATO
operation and Kosovo for example is
viewed as an illegal operation by the
United Nations there's no secret about
that the operation was clearly illegal
under the UN Charter the UN Charter is a
treaty it's a positive law obligation of
the United States we have done nothing
in the press to publicize the illegality
of that operation the result has been
not a successful operation but the
handing of Kosovo over to a group of
people who have difficulty administering
the country atrocities against Serbs as
there have been Serbian atrocities
against Kosovar Albanians and frankly in
my own experience atrocities are not
limited to one side or another there are
right-wing nuts on all sides and there
are left wing nuts and there are a lot
of innocent folks in the middle who get
hurt by both sides
secondly international law is not does
not involve personal crimes I know that
a lot of international lawyers disagree
with that statement unprepared to take
them all on I have in a number of
articles there is simply no I repeat no
evidence in the usual logic of
international lawyers to support the
notion of an International Criminal
Court other than the positive law
document concluded in Rome in 1998
Victor's justice like in nürnberg
applied our version of international law
to the defeated enemy it did not apply
our version of international to our own
people who admitted war crimes there are
documented evidence of this for example
the note was passed to the court during
the trial of Admiral Donuts saying it
was a war crime for him personally to be
involved in the unrestricted submarine
warfare decree that Germany had made
Admiral Nimitz submitted a letter saying
under orders from Washington he had
issued an identical decree on December
7th 1941 as far as I know Admiral Nimitz
has never been tried for the crime for
which Dennis was convicted in fact he
was never even held before a domestic
tribunal in fact if I remember correctly
he was given a ticker tape parade the
the notion that the International
Criminal Court will work therefore
assumes that we are prepared to have our
people tried for the same things that we
say others violate international law by
doing it has never never happened except
in Victor's justice courts never I
repeat never the there are all sorts of
reciprocal operations about which we
purport to get upset from time to time
for example in the last election there
was a big fuss made about Chinese paying
the Democratic Party for helping support
its campaign and yet I saw not a mention
in the press of the things that
Christopher talks about the United
States paying various folks in Greece
Portugal elsewhere Indonesia for
to affect their local elections
obviously the things that we do come
back to haunt us we fuss about them when
they're against our entry the perceived
interest of those who are fussing we do
not fuss about them when those people
sort of neglect the rules of reciprocity
thirdly I would emphasize that
immorality is not illegalities and
illegality is not personal criminal
liability as a matter of first of all
the word justice is not a word in the
legal order it's a word in the moral
order Aristotle wrote a book about it
actually Nicomachean ethics the ethics
is the Greek word that's equivalent to
the mores in Latin which is frequently
translated practices or justice morality
Aristotle wrote that there are at least
three different kinds of justice
commutative justice distributive justice
rectify turi justice
he didn't mention retributive justice
there are many other categories of
justice there probably a dozen or more
but when we speak of justice therefore
it behooves us to understand what we're
talking about some people will never be
satisfied that justice is done until the
world is empty to everybody but
themselves and their family or their
tribe otherwise everything is
self-defense including the actions by
the United States in Vietnam and
elsewhere including the actions by
Vietnamese or bin Laden against the
United States these are regarded as
divine law decrees in the interest of
justice as defined by the people who
blasphemously attribute to God their own
interpretations I say it's blasphemous
because by all religions that I know of
including the Muslim religion it is
blasphemous to presume to know the will
of God and yet we're surrounded with
people who know that will who claim to
know that well might say before going on
one of the notions I tell the my
students right away is I know I'm
fallible because I'm a younger brother I
knew when I was three years old my big
brother who was six years old was
infallible and he made it quite clear
that I was fallible the
from that lesson this evolves over time
of course when you're 14 your parents
become fallible and you become
infallible by the time you're 20 they've
learned a great deal in any event the
from this flow to corollaries well if
I'm fallible it's likely that you are
too I don't know that you are it's
likely second assuming that you can
convince me that you're infallible I
might be wrong because I'm fallible
therefore I would never accept the word
of jerry falwell
or Henry Kissinger or anybody else as to
anything whether or not I can check the
primary sources because I'm fallible the
moral remedy
therefore for these moral delict for
these Latin for the lack of perceived
justice is not a criminal trial the
moral remedy is sunning somebody its
exposure exposure has been the role of
the press the media in the United States
it has failed mr. Kissinger is getting
as I understand it about $30,000 per
speech who's paying him has there been
no fuss about the people who are paying
him why is there not an outcry of those
whose moral level is so poor that they
pay Kissinger $30,000 for an appearance
other remedies are Truth and
Reconciliation commissions there's been
no talk in the United States that I know
of a truth commission exposure is the
job of the press I would argue that the
to conceal the primary evidence in the
Library of Congress or elsewhere is not
only legal but in criminal actions in
the United States we have a privilege
against self-incrimination it seems to
me that that privilege and
self-incrimination indicates among other
things a weakness of applying criminal
law remedies even domestic criminal law
remedies where they might exist to the
to these matters these are political
faults these are things
demand exposure if democracy is to work
they must be exposed they are not being
fully exposed until Christopher began
his his articles except in the extreme
left-wing press that nobody reads and it
seems to me that there are remedies
available and I wish people would go to
them more often Thank You Roger
I suppose I have the dubious distinction
here of being the only member of the
panel who has actually worked for a war
criminal I wanted to respond just very
briefly to some of the comments that
were made earlier
Christopher's quite right I think that
the collusion with the South Vietnamese
regime prior to mr. Nixon's first
election was a great constitutional
crime there is of course no enduring
honor among constitutional scoundrels
within three months I know personally
Christopher the United States government
was was contemplating the assassination
of general Q because he proved to be
rather as you know recalcitrant from
time to time about American diplomacy
and and policy in Vietnam so the the
collusion the cooperation the
collaboration including covert money
from the South Vietnamese as well as
from the Greek hunter and others was was
very a very short duration there was
indeed a serious effort
Stanly in the early days of the the
Nixon administration to to negotiate a
peace in in Vietnam
Tony Lake and I were were personally
involved working for Kissinger in the
first covert peace talks
covert in the sense that they were
unknown even to the Secretary of State
or the Secretary of Defense anyone else
outside the White House in Paris we took
elaborate precautions to avoid
surveillance not by the Soviets or the
Chinese or any other power but by the
American government to conduct those
negotiations and there was on
table in the in the early spring of 1970
a negotiated withdrawal of all American
forces by the end of the year by the end
of 1970 that was interrupted by the
dementia not alas of Henry Kissinger but
of the man he worked for Richard Nixon
and and the ensuing Cambodian invasion
and you know the sequel several several
thousand Americans died in the years
that followed and several hundred
thousand Southeast Asians died of course
as a result I wanted to say to Stanley
that that if these transcripts are
revealing please be cautious one of my
assignments as as it was also Tony Lakes
after each of the of the sessions in
Paris with Leigh docto was to doctor the
transcripts so that Henry would look
good for posterity
there was a there was a deliberate and
conscious and very elaborate
falsification of the record including
the insertion sometimes of humorous and
and erudite remarks that had not in fact
been made at the table but which I think
would serve the historians well when
they came to to judge Henry's
statesmanship as well as his humor which
of course was I think almost as
important as his diplomatic achievements
I remember quite vividly in fact
spending a good deal of time writing
speeches and trying to confess for
appearances in this very building in
which he was as you must remember the
darling of the American press this war
criminal we now meet to excoriated to
expose oh was the the preeminent
celebrity of the Nixon years not only
because he was successful and not only
because he was charming at briefings but
because he trafficked in in that most
wonderful of all Washington commodities
the selective leak he was the
greatest leaker I think in the history
of American politics foreign or domestic
and it was not by accident that he was
appreciated by those to whom he leaked
he made careers possible salaries larger
and reputations I suspect more enduring
we shall not know all of his
transgressions in foreign policy ever I
suspect and we shall never know his
machinations with the Washington press
corps or on the hill which were equally
believe me equally impressive he spent
most of his time cultivating that
audience not plotting against a yen day
or or propagating genocide in Bangladesh
but making sure that Joe craft and the
times in the post and all the others
were well fed and nourished I must say
that that in a final comment about my
colleagues here it's quite true that
John Mitchell and Richard Nixon and
others were held accountable in some way
but my goodness we must remember no
American political figure has ever gone
to jail for an act of foreign policy of
any any dimension Richard Nixon was not
too driven from office because he bombed
Cambodia he violated other canons of the
elite but it was not the savaging of a
country from 30,000 feet with other
impunity it it really involved other
crimes other transgressions John
Mitchell did not go to jail hauled him
and did not go to jail Ehrlichman did
not go to jail for acts of foreign
policy in which of course they were all
they were all complicit that brings me
to just two or three brief remarks about
about Christopher's absolutely wonderful
work and I agree with with Alfred
exposure is everything we haven't begun
to have it yet in America in either
domestic or foreign policy we are really
still very much in the dark I would just
remind you that that though Henry
Kissinger's culpability is quite clear
he was never alone
he could not have conducted this savage
heedless criminal foreign policy by
himself he was surrounded by Kissinger's
Kissinger's and they were men who
profited personally materially in career
terms in terms of reputation in terms of
power almost as much as he only a few of
the names you know Alexander Haig when
we have your catalogue of future
secretaries of State Alexander Haig and
Larry Eagleburger and future national
security advisors Brent Scowcroft the
list goes on
you must understand of course that their
protegees populate the new
administration there is a direct
genealogical line between Henry
Kissinger and the national security
apparatus as it were of George W Bush
Henry's transgressions would not have
been possible without the active
intellectual and substantive support of
his aides
Edie Cory was a was an old journalist
who had been burned in career terms in
Eastern Europe after World War two he
was haunted by that by the communist
menace his cables from Santiago his
characterization of a yen day and his
regime his portrayal of that election
campaign had a great deal to do with the
mania that then overtook the White House
and Henry's orders did not go into the
ether they were executed and carried out
and supported it often enthusiastically
backed by an entire bureaucracy in the
Department of State and the Central
Intelligence Agency and the Pentagon
please don't assume that war criminals
are lone Ranger's despite Henry's
characterization of himself is that too
Oriana Fallaci
on one occasion he was never alone
Ranger he was the commandant of a
willing and eager army and they are men
who have equally escaped any
accountability even the kind of exposure
we're trying to give Kissinger here
today and they all they all went on not
only to new power but to wonderful lives
of respect in cinah cure and pensions
and academic postings etc etc etc
Henry's not the only one who is honored
by our culture his men were as well and
many of them are still alive I must just
say that that this strikes me as as very
encouraging that that you have come in
such numbers this morning I'm not
generally optimistic about the issue of
accountability in American foreign
policy I think there is no area to
paraphrase one of Lewis's wonderful
books there is no area in which there is
a greater wish for kings in American
life than in the conduct of our Foreign
Relations Henry Kissinger reflected then
as I think his successors have reflected
the overwhelming urges and prejudices of
the American people the racism that was
reflected in our policy in Southeast
Asia was a racism deeply embedded in
American society Henry was not an
aberration he was a kid from George
Washington High in the Bronx and I need
not remind you Harvard and he reflected
the values and the inner ethic the often
unspoken inner ethic of our most revered
institutions he got away with it not
because he was some sly magician or some
skillful manipulator he got away with it
because he reflected so often what so
many of his peers those above and below
and around him felt in the press in
Congress in the executive branch in the
bureaucracy in the political world in
the intellectual world in academia
he was quintessentially in his savagery
toward the outside world his
heedlessness his imperial
Imperial mentality reflective of very
powerful strains in American life and we
must not forget that he was not apart
from the main though we now single him
out for responsibility the
responsibility of course ultimately is
ours
thanks Christopher a closing word or a
comment on each of the remarks and then
we can turn it over to questions well
I'm just delighted that the other
panelists have have so much materialized
the the way in which how should we put
in Harper's place for very high stakes
we're not just talking about justice in
other words today ladies and gentlemen
but also about Freedom of Information
and the historical record so where these
are these are not minor potatoes and
therefore in seeking to clarify a case
against a successful example of the
criminal type in politics and to say
that's a reproach to the what we think
of as the prevailing standards we also
demand that the record become open and
that the historical record be inspected
because it belongs to us it's been
annexed chunks of it have been sawn off
and made into private property and
converted for private use with with
appalling distortions I'll give you one
example only the the word team or ti amo
are significant if ik another country in
Asia a whole country and cold society
and culture utterly devastated by Henry
Kissinger's attentions does not appear
in his own memoirs out of which he's
made a fortune in which he qualified
himself to write by having been
Secretary of State but it's up to him
what is going to be included in that
record or not this is a fantastic abuse
not just of the free information process
but also of the historical record itself
and and demands redress now I'm also
very glad that Roger turned the fire
little on my own profession
it's appalling to me that Henry
Kissinger should appear in the mass
media not as I dentists assume he
appears in an orange jumpsuit at all
times though that well I'll step lightly
over that but but more often as an
independent and objective commentator
than then as a subject of scrutiny in
other words his opinion and advice or
sort as if they were neutral by people
like Ted Koppel and by people like Jim
Lehrer and so on by the Los Angeles
Times op-ed page and the op-ed page of
our own hometown rag the Washington Post
which had to be written to I think
perhaps 50 times by groups of
congressmen and others before it would
identify mr. Kissinger as other than a
former Secretary of State when he was
writing about business relations with
China in which he had a direct interest
it took a long time to get the
Washington Post to add that tagline
simply that the author of this piece has
an interest in the outcome of the
argument there's a great cause for
reproach in other words in in our
profession having failed to do this and
finally since we may as well leave no
one standing while we're about it
implied in what everything I've written
is a is a rebuke to the fantastically
complacent and overfed community the
American human rights set I believe if
you lived in New York or Washington and
you were a member of any Committee on
human rights very sort you probably need
never dine alone almost every night of
the week someone is giving another
member of this community a Human Rights
Award for their brave work on as it
might be Street Lanka or the Taliban and
only the other day I saw Ariane Iyer who
must be the absolute czar and Pope of
this community writing long and
thoughtful room initiative peace grazing
on the lower slopes of international
morality in the New York Review of Books
the question before him was how should
we deal with the monsters of this world
what for example to do to bring slobodan
milosevic
to justice and so and I read our page
through not a word within a few blocks
of where he was writing this article in
midtown Manhattan sits the proper object
of his attention
and until this this Caliban and mirror
relationship can be brought into a finer
alignment it seems to me a mockery is
made of all the customary standards by
which our press and human rights and
freedom of information and historical
truth seminars are carried on well thank
you anyway
Thanks we have questions we have about
half an hour I think you have to get
close to a microphone if you're going to
ask a question they're there so and
please direct a question that whichever
panelists you feel best suited to answer
it
well I'm al Milliken with Washington
infinite writers but this would be to
anyone that has followed in recent
months the United States government
dealing with the massacre of civilians
going back to the Korean War and as
anyone see a correlation how they've
been dealing with that situation at that
time is as how they're dealing with what
you've uncovered about Henry Kissinger
in his associates well I would think
Roger Morris might answer that because
that goes to what kind of a country we
are I mean that's the question you
raised that Kissinger is not acting
alone and then you're alluding to the
new gunnery investigation yes let me
just say I was I was in the White House
on the on the National Security Council
staff when the first released serious
evidence of the me ly massacre was
presented to to the administration and
like all these matters it was not viewed
I'm afraid in moral or legal terms it
was not even viewed essentially in
diplomatic terms for what it might mean
in terms of the conduct of the war in in
Southeast Asia but rather as a domestic
political problem
and not even then as a problem involving
so much the American people as the
president's relationship with the
American military who even as he was
contemplating what to do about this was
spying on him quite quite actively it's
important to remember that this
government is a court of the Borgias and
has been for some time and I suspect
will remain so and these are not matters
that can be dealt with in camera in any
responsible way the only hope is to deal
with them in the open and that comes
back to to you of course to the press
I think the hill is hopeless and so the
only the only real chance at
accountability is is exposure and that's
that's coercion that's forcing them to
do something against all of their
instincts and against their will but the
handling of the Korean massacre is just
exactly a characteristic it seems to me
was a question from here you gentlemen
is about to get the microphone I wonder
if one of you would discuss I mean the
issue of sovereign immunity which is
really what what we're talking about
there's a subtext here which probably
needs some legal discussion and perhaps
the more personal
yes but exposure and disclosure about
henry kissinger walter isaacson seymour
hersh the church committee hasn't me the
slightest bit of difference in his
reputation in his life so would you
comment on that why is it it doesn't
take Mary I I remember you and I tried
this even when I was still working for
the administration if you'll if you'll
recall it doesn't take I think because
it's of not sufficient shock value I
don't think we've ever really gotten
close to the heart of the matter as
Christopher has gotten in these two
pieces I think there's been a lot of
surface smut but I don't think we've
really put it all together the way the
way Hitchens has in these in these two
articles and I think quite frankly that
this is an incremental process I think
the education of the American people is
a very slow and agonizing business
especially in foreign affairs and we
benefit in part from the the trail of
scandal and and of disgrace and of
dishonor that followed Kissinger with
other politicians we are now much more
sophisticated it seems to me about both
our domestic order and about our conduct
in the world and it doesn't seem
hopeless that we would come at some
point to a to a reckoning so I don't I
don't count the the failure of previous
expose or disclosure as all that
decisive I think it is incremental and I
think we need a great deal more good we
have professor Rubin on that question
because this is about exposure and this
is your remedy well there let me let me
answer two questions then the first with
regard to exposure the US has been
notoriously two-faced about it for
example we argued for command
responsibilities in the so-called you
monster case after the Second World War
we're an American military commission
held at Muramasa had violated
international law by not controlling the
troops that were notionally at least
some distant way under his command in
Manila but we acquitted
captain Medina after the malai massacre
under a charge that was totally
inconsistent with the the earlier master
case we we tend not to try our own
people for doing the things that we
blame others for doing same things going
on in Logan Rhee we understand why our
people to save their own lives shot a
lot of innocent civilians we don't
understand why the other side might
shoot a lot of innocent civilians to
save what they fancy to be there I'm a
pop or whatever as far as sovereign
immunity is concerned the American
courts have been notoriously confused
about it and the reason why in well way
back you may remember in the American
Journal of international law this was
discussed in 1975 or 76 when this
foreign Sovereign Immunities Act was
before it was passed the only addition
of the Proceedings of the american
society in which those who spoke from
the floor are not identified by name the
reason for that is is fairly clear it's
not admitted by the people who were
running the thing at the time lemis is
clear those who spoke against the act
where people like Mars mcdougal of Yale
Mike Cardozo myself not that matters
very much but anyhow there were a number
of people who spoke against the act
saying it wouldn't work the way it's
planned but monroe lee was behind it and
he was the legal adviser and that was
that there are two problems in sovereign
immunity
first of all solid immunity runs to
sovereigns that is two states and not
two individuals the for the foreign
sovereign immunity Act in effect says
that when the foreign sovereign acts in
a commercial capacity then he can be
sued as if he's a an ordinary
corporation that's fairly clear every
corporation in the United States after
all is the result of an act of some
legislature or some executive branch
appropriate documents even if your
DuPont in in Delaware you you owe your
legal existence to some legal act by
somebody on power to act in that way
therefore all corporations in the United
States are in effect branches of the
sovereign in that they're licensed by
the sovereignty to be an individual
person whether am torg the former USSR
Trading Corporation is the equivalent or
I see I the British Imperial chemical
industries or other things are the same
category we say that's a matter for the
US courts and they should apply a rule
of whether the acts are jury just the
illness that is commercial acts or jury
imperiai and the US Supreme Court has
split notoriously on delicate cases in
fact the two leading cases split believe
it or not three two one two one two four
in one of the cases where three plus one
plus one made the five man majority so
the three man minority wrote the
majority opinion in effect even though
only three concurred in it and the other
one was four to one to four year later
in which the one made one of the four
into five and was clearly absurd it said
you know this act is certainly a
sovereign act when sorry it was
certainly a commercial act but in fact
it had the case been tried in the
country involved there's no question
that there would have been no recovery
so it was clearly illegal Act which is a
sovereign act the Supreme Court has not
heard a serious sovereign immunities
case other than an Argentine a case
where we held nine to nothing that a
particular act was not entitled to a
sovereign immunity they alone which was
clearly in contradiction to a Nicaraguan
case holding exactly the opposite a
couple of years before why it's got nine
to nothing in that particular case I
don't know I presume that the parties
had negotiated something out of court or
or whatever and the newspapers never
picked it up as far as I know therefore
the US Supreme Court has never made up
its mind on sovereign immunity won't
hear a case if it does it will come
five two four or six two three again
nobody will know what the proper answer
is and the result of that is that if
you've got a case against a foreign
sovereign the chances are you'll settle
it out of court rather than waste the
money on lawyers to get a decision that
is not going to be meaningful that has
to be distinguished from the choice of
law situation once a case is before the
courts there is a question that the
American courts will try to answer as to
what body of law applies to govern the
case in a civil case it's been fairly
clear since 1830 for some Joseph's story
wrote the book on the subject that there
is a choice of law involved there are
some cases where we will apply Cuban law
or Argentine law or what have you we
abandoned that in the so called
filartiga case where we applied what we
call international law to the acts a
foreign individual now sovereign
immunity had nothing to do with the case
this was a choice of law decision and it
went peculiarly enough under the Alien
Tort Claims provision of the Judicature
Act of 1789 which in fact if you read it
carefully makes no sense at all none the
if you read it with any knowledge of the
history for example noting that
international is not identical with the
law of nations of 1789 noting that for a
hundred and fifty years after story
wrote his book there has been no case
under the foreign Sovereign Immunities
Act the reasons are absolutely clear the
constitutional provision changed its
meaning international law is not the
same as the law of nations it's you're
skint it's u.s. gentium is not the same
as used in turgon taste to use the latin
phrases which therefore must be
important therefore I find that
sovereign immunity would be no defense
to Kissinger but act but the choice of
law problem would apply and the question
would be what law applies is it American
law in which case he's not guilty of
anything we're all guilty or is it
international law in which case it seems
to me he gets all free because
international law has never except in
Victor's tribunals held a person to be a
criminal at international law and I
wrote
book on piracy at one time where I
looked at all the piracy presidents it's
just not true the arguments that you
hear bluntly from human rights lawyers
piracy is not the paradigmatic offense
it's a municipal law offense always has
been always as far as I can see will be
thank you before the question before
your question
Stanley one or it's got very big yeah
but briefly okay I just want to respond
to Mary Majoris question here indeed it
is a bit of a mystery how there are
these critical things that are said and
done about mr. Kissinger his reputation
remains really the rather high but I
would distinguish for you between your
world and another world I suppose these
days we call it spin control
Roger Boras she was the wonderful word
before speaking of Henry Kissinger's
master nations I think that this is a
full-time enterprise on his part you
remember when he was in government there
were reporters who would follow him
around and made good money writing books
about him and about his diplomacy those
were books as told to by Henry Kissinger
there was no digging into sources no
wide-range of anything rivaling
scholarship and so forth and what's
fascinating hear about Hitchens's work
to me is that he has done what is often
not done in that world he has looked at
a multiplicity of sources he's looked at
archival primary documents it would have
been very very easy to write about Henry
Kissinger and his policies by just
asking for an interview and let Henry
Kissinger tell you what happened which
is what usually does result from these
kinds of works as you see Christopher
did try to interview mr. Kissinger but
to no avail
who knows they had he done it maybe he
could have found Christopher a little
soft in the head and convert him I doubt
that but he might but the but there's a
there's a question here of really of the
responsibility of the media
people who report these things they want
access they want access you don't
certainly think that somebody like Ted
Koppel is going to be that critical of
him once about his program
he's got star appeal so to speak but
that's what I mean I I think it's a
question of preserving one's one's
access and and sources and there's a
reluctance to be critical here
there are as you correctly pointed out
there is some criticism but uh it hasn't
stood much of a chance against all this
other stuff first you and then and then
you okay having plowed through this very
formidable body of work I'd like to ask
Christopher if you could clarify one
particular point for me on which I'm
still not clear and and that is how we
define and trace the precise distinction
between an utterly ruthless realpolitik
as carried out by great powers for many
many generations and a personal
indictable responsibility for an act of
international crime and I'm still a
little bit unclear about whether there
is a border between those two in your
thinking or whether that this is in a
sense indictment one in a whole litany
of potential indictments that can then
go on to include for example Margaret
Thatcher over the sinking of the
Belgrano the late Leonid Brezhnev over
Soviet behavior in in Afghanistan and so
on are you are you arguing that there is
something about the Kissinger record
that is unique above and beyond and
wicked beyond the beyond the ordinary
wickedness of superpowers and
realpolitik oh I'm so sorry
you should have said before well Mary
McCrory
said a few minutes ago that after all
think of how many times kissing has been
exposed by sy Hersh or
the church committee or Walter
Isaacson's or will the Church Committee
and Walter Isaacson both examined the
case of general Schneider the one with
which I opened my bed today and
concluded the occasion hadn't had him
killed I a fantastic conclusion from the
available evidence to him even then they
said it was a kidnap thing that went
botched probably absolutely not true
it's a it's it's every stage of it now
can be demonstrated and now I think it's
only really with the final disclosures
that arose from the Hinchey amendment
last year which forced the CIA to
disgorge fully what had done initially
we've only known since I think it's
about November of the giving of 35 grand
which is a lot of money in 9:31 prices
to the people who'd killed Schneider
after they'd finished the job okay not
the sort of sum that could be dispersed
I think by local station chief either
probably involving the knowledge of
someone chairing the 40 committee I
would think but once you've once you've
established that money was paid to the
murderers after the murders been done
then all the stuff in Isaacson and the
Church Commission is shown to be
nonsense and a euphemism because once
that final bit is in place all the a
words kick in aiding the betting
accessory accomplice and that's a murder
case and there's no law as far as I know
this will allow someone to say well it's
okay I did have this guy killed in
another country who'd never done
anything to me or to anyone else but I
but I did it because the president told
me to if that can be entered as a
defense I would like to see it entered
as a defense okay but first someone
somebody has to say you can't do that or
they all they I would just as soon hear
them say and shake it shake professor
Reubens I think well the pessimistic but
very forensic line on this very well
then let us have it said that there is
legal as long as you are in America
let's have that clarified to
what what cannot go on doing is living
in this semi-opaque a world of multiple
standards if standards they may be
called now to your question isn't
anything unique about the good doctor
and would it be the case that if we went
after we'd have to go after everyone
else in history as well I'm for example
one of those is completely fascinated
with the question why does most what why
do most school productions of Henry v
leave out the bit where Shakespeare puts
in King Henry's massacre of the French
prisoners at Agincourt and should this
case not be reopened and should we now
not rather view king henry v in the
light of a war criminal I'm all for that
I love these kinds of arguments again
but I also have a maxim permanently in
my head in these matters don't make the
best the enemy of the good okay in the
case of Kissinger we have someone who's
still around very much in our midst and
we have all the evidence about the
crimes that he committed in a series of
countries making it look as if
aberrations are couldn't form a defense
say in the matter of Vietnam or Cambodia
or Chile or Laos or Bangladesh or Cyprus
or East Timor because after a bit it
stops looking like coincidence okay I
was going to call this Henry portrait of
a serial killer but then I thought that
might be offensive to some potential
readers so we call it a war criminal
instead but here we have such a case
here we have such a test case in the
making and here we have international
law and customary law evolving somewhat
with the arrest of Pinochet and the
warrant for Milosevic and we know and I
have the tape and it's in the harpist
piece that mr. Kissinger is smarter than
we are he knows he could be in legal
jeopardy for the Sneijder business he
knows he could be the subject of a
variant or claims suit brought by
Chilean relatives he knows he knows all
this credit he knows he has to be
careful where he travels I make a little
holiday in my heart every time I hear
this he's told various associates
Affairs he's not sure he can go to
anymore okay he's only welcome in
certain rather grungy salons in New York
these days it's not punishment enough in
my view I think we should proceed
further with it so that's my answer to
that the the extradition laws of the
United States we do not have any
exception for American nationals
unlike Chile or Libya where there's no
extradition treaty
the US has extradition treaties with
many countries including Spain and we do
not accept American nationals from their
operation therefore if any Latin
American well known about that American
countries but if many countries in
Europe would like or elsewhere would
like to extradite Henry Kissinger they
can bring a case right now in an
American Court now I bet you that Henry
Kissinger knows all about that before
I'm going to ask is this woman here
before I ask that before you they go
answer it before you ask the question
Martin I would think one of the things
that's unique about Kissinger is how
small the stakes are I mean it's usually
about his own career he's prepared as
opposed to the ruthless realpolitik
which is reasons of the state or has a
larger purpose and with most of
Kissinger's actions it's about his
personal advancement and it strikes me
is fairly unique okay another question
for Christopher Hitchens so I guess
you'll have to stand up again
so you may have already answered this
question would you the testers of that
site okay as you know there's some
effort now to bring penetrated trial and
he was released by the British as we all
know and I calls to my Tom Hauser's book
on the execution of Charles Horman where
Corman's father said that the reason why
the United States wouldn't allow Chile
to be blamed was because Chile would
turn right around and point the finger
at Kissinger or at the United States do
you think that the release of Chile of
President former president Pinochet from
England and the fact that he may be now
described as unfit to stand trial is an
effort to protect those in this country
who one could say created Peniche or
certainly subsidized him and is it also
possible that Kissinger is being spared
because he represents their interests
and disclosed her as he could turned
around say the president gave me orders
to that's a fairly complex question but
I know you can get to the core of it but
I think I understand the grammar of the
question for example well there are two
things one is kissing is suborning of
murder in chile helps bring to power a
government in chile which replays the
united states service peak if we can
confuse the United States and Henry
Kissinger for a second which I admit is
an obscenity but just for the vernacular
purposes replays the United States in
the same coin by letting off a car bomb
a few hundred yards from here at rush
hour which kills orlando letelier's are
late and great comrade and his American
citizen friend and driver running with
him that's still illegal in the United
States by the way you can't let off car
bombs at Russia I'm downtown Washington
DC especially not if there's an American
citizen being killed that's still
there's no law that says you can do that
and gradually and Scott knows more about
this case than anyone we have again
another lay down case
know exactly how that murder was
commissioned and authored and carried
out and paid for and it leads right back
to finish it and it's it is still
possible if not well the u.s. indictment
will have to be made of the good general
it was Henry Kirsten is clad so it goes
around it comes around these two skeins
of investigation also do touch upon the
material he has tried to sequester in
the Library of Congress so I think he
feels these threads slightly tightening
around his pudgy neck and and I think
that he should do so and I was very
intrigued to see the other day a
statement it was carried by the German
press agency and just given to me
yesterday of a press conference in
Barcelona of some of the Chilean and
Spanish magistrates who've been involved
in the the attempt to bring death squad
re within the reach of international law
saying that they want to proceed with
the Pinochet case to extend it to Henry
Kissinger it's the logical next step was
Pinochet as a torturer and assassin and
author of disappearances and kidnaps and
murders and so was after all not acting
on his own was acting as the instrument
of a certain policy by a certain
superpower the threads of which ran
through a certain twist so yes that the
skein is tightening
we have another question for mr. Morris
azusa's Cavell from the Mexican news
agency my question is about Chile - it's
so frustrating for a Latin American
journalist as myself when you go to the
State Department of the White House to
ask questions about the documents that
have been released on the case of mr.
Pino jet and in Baldwin or mr. Henry
Kissinger the answer is always is a
matter of national security and they
don't want to put in risk that national
security my basic question to you is is
a really risk of the national security
of the United States given names or put
in or taking of those black ink over the
lines of those documents or is a matter
trying to defend personalities as mr.
Henry Kissinger I must say in in my
experience there there are there are
very very few matters that are withheld
from the American public or the Congress
or from history in the redacted
documents that are genuinely matters of
national security I would it would be
hard to estimate but I would say 90 to
95 percent of the secrets kept by the
American government are secrets of
expedience and political convenience
usually attended on the on the
administration in power but sometimes
the reputations of people who are still
powerful like Henry Kissinger so that
his successors would in their own
interest of course and as part of the
club mentality that that obtains here
try to prevent the release of
incriminating documents this is as a
famous governor of ours in New Mexico
once said a whole box full of Pandora's
once you start opening this box
culpability as I said earlier does not
stop with with Henry Kissinger the
foreign policy establishment and by
larger extension that the
the American political establishment has
has a very great stake in in the the
maintenance of these secrets and Henry's
secrets as Christopher begins to suggest
curl far beyond murder and mayhem and
genocide and great crimes of state they
curl back to corporate and and other
collusions that are with us even today
ultimately what's at stake here is not
the national security but national
profit and a good deal of money was was
made the the the foundation for the
current oligarchy that that that
prevails in American policy today
foreign and domestic was laid during the
Nixon years so these these are very
momentous matters but don't let anybody
tell you that it's authentic national
security that's that's nonsense this is
self protection but until we change our
methods of governance you're stuck with
it I think we have to stop we've come to
11 o'clock and we could go a long time
but I'm grateful to the panelists I'm
grateful to Christopher I would like and
admire all the people on the panel I'm
sorry I can't hear more from them and
I'm also grateful to all of you for
coming thank you very very much